Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Ahmet Asliyuce
Bundan üç sene önce 13 yaşında bir
çocuk olduğunuzu hayal etmenizi istiyorum,
13 yaşında babasını yeni
kaybetmiş, annesi ve kardeşiyle
hayata tutunmaya çalışan, bu yolculukta
kendini ve tutkularını arayan bir çocuk.
Bu çocuk tutkularını bulabilmek için;
spordan sanata, tiyatrodan okuldaki
farklı görevlere kadar her şeyi denemiş,
bunlardan belli bir deneyim edinmiş,
ama hâlâ tutkularını bulamamış.
Bu çocuk, çok hırslı ve çok meraklı
ve bu çocuk üç sene önce bir kış günü,
şu anki tutkularının ilk tohumlarını
buluyor ve şu an o tutkularıyla beraber,
kendini bulmaya bir adım daha yaklaşıyor.
Merhabalar, ben Mehmet Ali
Makbuloğlu ve memnun oldum,
ben o tutkularını arayan çocuğum.
(Alkış)
Peki, üç sene önce ne oldu da ben
şu anki yaşadığım tutkularımı buldum?
Biz üç sene önce Beykoz'da
oturuyorduk ve bir kış günü,
benim kardeşim Mustafa hastalanmıştı.
O zamanlar, kardan dolayı araba
hiçbir şekilde çıkmıyordu
ve evde de ilaç yoktu...
Bize en yakın eczane, tamı tamına
dört kilometre uzaklıktaydı
ve o dönemde ailem, kardeşime alternatif
çözümler bulmaya çalışırken,
ben de salonda oturuyordum.
Bir tarafta boş bir ilaç kutusu,
bir tarafta da drone'umu gördüm.
Ben evde dolaşmayı çok severim,
ayakta dolaşırım, düşünürüm,
kendi kendime konuşurum
ve bir taraftan boş ilaç kutusunu,
öbür taraftan drone'u aldım.
Sonra, bir anda ikisini üst üste koydum.
Sonra aklımda bir ışık çaktı
ve ben ilacı drone'a iple bağladım.
Sonra ben drone'u havalandırdım,
drone önüme geldiğinde,
ipi kestim ve ilaç yere düştü.
Büyük bir heyecanla kendime dedim ki,
''Biz eczaneye gidemiyorsak,
eczane niye bize gelmiyor?''
Fikir çok basitti, nöbetçi eczanelerden
veya ulaşımı zor olan yerlere yakın olan
eczanelerden, bir drone ilaç alacaktı,
bunu taşıyacaktı ve insanlara verecekti.
Beni çok heyecanlandırmıştı bu fikir,
hemen akşamında oturup çizmeye başladım.
Tatil bitti, sabah Bilişim Teknolojileri
öğretmenimin kapısına gittim ve çaldım.
Açtığında, ''Hayırdır Mali?'' dedi.
''Öğretmenim ben eczanelerden
ilaç alıp insanlara teslim eden
bir drone yapmak istiyorum'' dedim.
''Tamam, çok güzel ama ilk önce drone'u
nasıl yapacağını öğrenmen gerekiyor.''
Bunu bana söylediğinde,
eve gittim, açtım bilgisayarımı
ve yazdığımda internete,
karşıma bir video çıktı.
Bir çocuk, elinde bir drone'la insanlara
21. yüzyıl becerilerini, maker hareketini
ve bu drone'u, o uçan drone'u, bu
beceriler sayesinde yaptığını söylüyordu.
Şimdi o videoyu izledikten sonra dedim ki,
''Ya acaba benim de bu şekilde
mi yapmam gerekiyor?'
İnternete iki tane anahtar kelime yazdım:
''Maker'' ve ''Türkiye''
Karşıma bir internet sitesi
çıktı, ''Makers Türkiye.''
Yanında tırnak içinde,
sen de yap yazıyordu.
O cümle beni çok heyecanlandırmıştı,
çünkü ben de yapabilecektim.
Mail attım, dedim böyle böyle bir projem
var, bana yardımcı olur musunuz.
Ertesi gün Ongun Tandan,
Ongun abiden bir mail geldi.
''Merhaba Mehmet Ali,
hayaline yardımcı olmak isteriz.
Cuma günü kahve içmeye bekliyoruz.''
Bu mail'i aldıktan sonra, o mail'i okulda
aldım, ders sırasında ve çok mutlu oldum.
Böyle gülücükler saçıyorum
ve cuma günü gittim.
Onla konuştuk ve bana
yine şunları söyledi,
Maker kültürü sayesinde, 21.
yüzyıl becerilerini kullanarak
bu projeni yapacaksın.
İşte açık kaynak platformlar kullanacaksın
yazılım yapacaksın, tasarım yapacaksın,
ama benim burada
seçtiğim iki kavram vardı:
21. yüzyıl becerileri ve maker hareketi.
Şimdi ben bu iki kavramı anladıktan sonra,
benim hayatım ortadan ikiye bölündü.
Bir zaman çizelgesi düşünün,
ortada bir milat çizgisi,
bu milat çizgisi maker hareketini ve 21.
yüzyıl becerilerini anladığım zaman;
bunun öncesi, ''Maker Hareketinden Önce''
ve bunun sonrası da, ''Maker Hareketinden
Sonra'' diye adlandırıyorum.
Peki, bunca dakikadır konuştuğum şey,
maker hareketi ve
21. yüzyıl becerileri ne?
Maker hareketinin kökeni, ''maker'',
o videoda gördüğüm çocuk
Kaan abinin anlatımıyla,
make, yapmaktan geliyor, yani sen de yap.
Maker kültürü insana şunu diyor,
''Öğretirken öğren, kendin yap ve
bunu yaparken açık kaynağı kullan.''
Yani insanı yapmaya, öğretmeye
ve öğrenmeye teşvik ediyor.
Öğretirken öğren, ne? Onu
şöyle örnek verebilirim.
O videoda gördüğüm çocuk, Kaan
bana drone'u nasıl yapmayı anlatırken,
kendi de aslında drone'un nasıl daha
inovatif yapabileceğini öğreniyordu.
Aynı şekilde ilerleyen zamanlarda ben,
benden küçük çocuklara tasarım odaklı
düşünme dersleri verirken,
aslında ben de tasarımı
nasıl daha inovatif
yapabileceğimi öğreniyordum.
Yani öğretirken, öğreniyordum.
Dedim ki, ben maker kültürü yardımıyla
bu eczane drone projemi yapıyordum,
nasıl yapıyordum?
Ben ilk prototipimi yaparken,
kendin yap ve açık kaynak
felsefesini kullandım.
Michigan Teknik Üniversitesi'nin
yaptığı bir araştırmaya göre,
eğer bir aile hırdavat ihtiyaçlarını satın
almak yerine 3D printer'dan basarsa,
o dönem içinde, yüzde doksan
üçlük bir tasarruf yapıyor.
Yani ben 100 lira harcıyorsam, 100
liraya değil, 7 liraya mâl edebilirim.
Bu gerçekten çok büyük bir şey.
Ben de bu projeyi yaparken, 2000-3000
liraya bir drone alabilirdim, onun yerine
400 liraya kendi drone'umu
yapmaya karar verdim.
Peki, nasıl yaptım?
Ben bu projeye başlarken, bir
özgüvenim bir heyecanım vardı,
tutkularımı arıyordum çünkü,
ama bilgim yoktu.
Bunun için de, açık kaynağı kullandım.
Açık kaynak size şunu sağlıyor,
mesela ben drone nasıl yapılır
diye internete yazdığımda,
önüme yüzlerce video geldi.
Aynı şekilde drone'un yazılımı nasıl
yapılır diye yazdığımda, kod dökümanları;
tasarım nasıl yapılır diye yazdığımda
da, yüzlerce tasarım dökümanı geldi.
Ama işin en güzel kısmı burada değil,
işin en güzel kısmı bunu paylaşan insanlar
sizden tek kuruş bile para istemiyor.
Orada insanlar paylaşıyorlar
ve siz onlardan alıyorsunuz,
onları modifiye ediyorsunuz,
kullanıyorsunuz ve geri paylaşıyorsunuz.
Bu paylaşımcı topluluk, bu sayede
kendini bir adım daha öne taşıyor.
Tamam, bu benim birinci tutkum.
Peki ikinci tutkum ne,
21. yüzyıl becerileri ne?
Sinan Yaman'ın çok güzel bir sözü var:
''Egosu küçük, kalbi büyük, zihni berrak,
elleri hızlı, vicdani ve mantık zekâsına
sahip bireylerdir 21. yüzyıl bireyleri.''
Bunu şöyle anlatalım, 20. yüzyılda
yani bir önce bıraktığımız yüzyılda,
iki farklı kesim vardı: bir
aktivistler, bir de fabrikatörler,
ben onlara böyle diyorum.
Aktivistler vicdana sahiplerdi, liderlik
edebiliyorlardı ve hayal edebiliyorlardı,
ama üretemiyorlardı.
Aynı şekilde fabrikatörler üretebiliyordu,
ama hayal edemiyorlardı, gelecekteki
trendi görebiliyorlardı,
ama vicdana sahip değillerdi.
Şimdi 21. yüzyılda, bu ikisi birleşiyor.
Vicdan ve mantıksal zekâ birleşiyor
ve 21. yüzyıl bireyleri hem lider,
hem üretebilen, hem hayal edebilen,
hem de gelecekteki trendleri
yakalayabilen bireyler oluyor.
Çok güzel, oluyorlar ama
bir işi nasıl sürdürüyorlar?
Nasıl hayata geçirebiliyorlar?
İşte burada da Atatürk bize diyor ki,
''Hayallerimi belirledim, hayallerimin
önündeki engelleri gördüm, hayallerimin
önündeki engelleri kaldırınca,
hayallerim kendiliğinden gerçekleşti.''
Biz buna, 21. yüzyılda daha kısa bir
ad koyuyoruz ve buna vizyon misyon
ve aksiyon döngüsü diyoruz.
Benim vizyonum; kendimi
bulmak, tutkularımı bulmaktı.
Bunun için ben misyon olarak,
kendime maker kültürünü,
21. yüzyıl birey becerilerini kendi
içimde yansıtmak, yaşatmak
ve projemi yapmak olarak belirledim,
ve aksiyonda bu belirlediğim misyonu
hayata geçirdim ve devam ettim.
Kendimi bulmaya bir adım daha yaklaştım.
Bunu anladıktan sonra,
hayatımın ikinci dönemi başladı.
Bu ikinci döneme ben ilk adımımı
attığımda, şunu fark ettim.
Herkes benim kadar şanslı değil.
Bunu çok iyi anlamanızı istiyorum.
Bugün Türkiye'de, her çocuk
bunların farkına varamıyor.
Farkına varanlar var, ama hepsi değil
ve ben bunu gördükten sonra,
kendime şunu görev edindim.
Herkesin farkında olmasını,
bir nebze sağlamak istiyorum.
Bunun için yapabileceğim,
benim için en mantıklı karar,
öğretmenlerle derdimi paylaşmaktı.
Ben de bunun için eğitim sempozyumlarında,
maker kültürünün önemini
ve 21. yüzyıl becerilerini anlattım.
Bunu anlattıkça bu öğretmenler,
benim hayalimi anlatarak diğer
insanlarla paylaştı ve maker kültürü benim
gibi birsürü arkadaşım sayesinde çoğaldı.
Bunu çoğaltırken sadece ben tek başıma
değildim, benim gibi yüzlerce arkadaşım
benim yaşımda, benim yaşımdan
büyük insanlar vardı ve şu an,
şu dönemde, maker kültürü Türkiye'de
daha fazla tanınıyor, daha fazla çocuk,
hayallerini gerçekleştirmeye
bir adım daha atabiliyor.
Bu topluma yaptığım bir kazançtı
ve kendime edindiğim görevi
yapmama yardımcı olmuştu,
ama benim için kazanç neydi?
Şimdi benim ailem her ne kadar
benim hevesimi kırmamak için
yapabilirsin Mali dese de, kendi
içlerinde şunu düşündüklerini
bir nebze bile biliyordum,
''Ya icat çıkarma başımıza.''
Ya da hani, hani 14 yaşındasın
ne yapabilirsin ki sen?
Hani onca insan yapamıyor,
sen mi yapacaksın?
Ama ben bunu insanlara anlattıktan
sonra fark ettiler ki aslında bu kültür
sayesinde herkes istediğini kolayca
yapabilir ve ben ailemden şu sözü duydum,
''Mali yap, sen de yap.''
Bunu duymak beni o kadar mutlu etti ki,
ben o gün şunun farkına varmıştım,
ben tutkularımı bulmuştum ve kendimi
bulmaya, gelecekteki beni bulmaya
bir adım daha yaklaşmıştım,
ama her şey istediğim gibi gitmedi.
Ben ilk protitipimi yaptım, değil mi?
Ben bu ilk protitipi uygun bir fiyata
da yaptım, bayağı uygun yani,
ama ilerleyen protitiplere
geçmeye çalıştığımda,
bunun çok zor olduğunu fark ettim.
Ben ilk versiyonda sadece uçan bir drone
yapmıştım, havalanan, dolaşan bir drone,
ama bunun ilerleyen versiyonlarında,
daha stabil uçması gerekiyordu,
bir ilaç taşıması gerekiyordu ve bunu
bir yere bırakması gerekiyordu.
Ben bu süreçleri yapmaya çalışırken
fark ettim ki, bunu yapmak çok zor.
Kişisel isteğe göre bir
drone yapmak çok zor
ve beni daha fazla yavaşlattığı için,
ben onu bırakmak zorunda kaldım,
ama ben onu bırakırken ona şunu dedim,
''Bana maker kültürünü kazandırdığın için,
21. yüzyıl becerilerini kazandırdığın için
ve drone'un nasıl yapılacağını öğretip
mekanik deneyim verdiğin için,
çünkü gerçekten drone'un nasıl
yapıldığını öğrendim bu arada,
sana teşekkür ederim.''
Ona teşekkür ettim ve onu bıraktım.
Bu kadar kolay olabileceğini
düşünmüyordum ama bıraktım.
İçimde biraz burukluk vardı, eve geldim,
kardeşim bana kapıda bakıyor böyle,
belli ki ikinci projemizin
fikrini verecekti ufaklık
ve dedi ki, ''Abi ben Star Wars
asilerin o uçağını yapmak istiyorum,
drone yapmak istiyorum, yapabilir miyim?''
Ya düşünsenize hani ben yapamamışım,
şimdi ailemin bana hissettiğini,
ben kardeşime hissediyorum.
(Gülerek)
Ya ben yapamadım, sen nasıl yapacaksın?
Gerçekten de öyle düşündüm.
Ben zorlandıysam, bu çocuk nasıl yapacak?
Şimdi bir drone deneyimi yaşamak
istediğinizde, önünüzde iki seçenek var.
Ya 2000-3000 liraya stabil uçan bir drone
alacaksınız, bir para kaybı vereceksiniz,
ya da daha uygun bir fiyata,
zamanınızı ve enerjinizi harcayarak
bir drone yapmaya çalışacaksınız.
Bu sorunu ben aklımın bir köşesine
kazımıştım ki, Atalay'la tanıştığımda
bu sorun tekrardan masaya geldi.
Atalay benim yaşıtım, o
buralarda bir yerde oturuyor
ve o da yazılım yapıyor,
ben mekanik tasarım alanında
devam etmeye karar
verdim, o yazılım yapıyor.
Biz onunla tanıştığımızda, fark ettik ki
gerçekten herkes istediği gibi orta yolda
bir drone yapamıyor, yani hem
uygun olacak hem de uğraştırmayacak,
böyle bir şey yapamıyorlar.
Böyle olunca biz bunun, sorunun
farkına varınca, biz Pira'ya başladık.
Pira, bizim şu an çalıştığımız,
üzerinde çalıştığımız yeni girişimimiz
ve biz Pira'da şunu dedik,
''Biz ne siyah olalım, ne de beyaz
olalım, biz gri olalım'' dedik.
Yani biz ne pahalı bir drone
yapalım, stabil bir drone yapalım,
ne de insanları uğraştıracak
bir şey yapalım dedik.
Uygun fiyatlı, stabil uçabilecek
ve kişiselleştirilebilir bir
drone yapalım dedik.
Çok basitti bunda da prensip,
bir ana gövde düşünün.
Şu anki versiyonumuzu anlatıyorum sizlere
ve dört tane de kol var
ve bu kollar ana gövdeye takılıyor
ve modüler bir şekilde havalanıyor.
Şimdi bu projeyi çalışırken, üzerinde
çalışırken, fark ettim ki Mustafa da
drone yapabilecek, o da o kolları takarken
onu yapmanın deneyimine erişebilecek
ve aynı zamanda bu, 2000-3000 lira değil,
biraz daha uygun bir fiyata olacaktı
ve şu an, biz 25 kişilik bir ekiple,
Pira üzerinde çalışıyoruz.
Bu ekibin güzel bir yanı var, biz
Atalay'la başvuruları açarken dedik ki,
bizden büyük insanların olması zorunlu
değil ya da cv'lerinde hangi üniversiteden
kaç derece aldıkları da umurumuzda değil
ya da hangi projelere öncülük
ettikleri de umurumuzda değil,
tabii ki önemli bunlar ama, biz onların
tutkularıyla ve hayalleriyle gelmesini
istiyoruz dedik, bu yüzden
başvurularımızı açtık
ve başvurularımıza şunu dedik,
''Bir alanda yetkinliğin var mı,
varsa bizim işimize yarayabilir.
Tutkuların neler ve bizim ekibimizde
neler yapmak istersin?''
ve bu insanlar başvurdular ve şu
an ekibimizdeki insanların her biri,
bir tutkuya, bir hayale sahip ve
bizim hayalimize ortak oluyorlar
ve biz bu projeyi, ilerleyen
adımlara götürüyoruz.
Şu an durum bu.
Ben bu kültürleri kendi içimde yaşamaya
başladıktan sonra ve projelerle beraber
devam ettikten sonra fark ettim ki, ben
kendimi bulmaya bir adım daha yaklaştım
ve ben bunları, bu iki tutku sayesinde
yaptım; 21. yüzyıl becerileri
ve maker hareketi sayesinde yaptım,
ama bunu bir tek ben yaptım
diye değil, hepiniz yapabilirsiniz.
Hepiniz gelecekteki kendinize,
bir adım daha, bir adım
daha yaklaşabilirsiniz
ve buna hemen başlayabilirsiniz.
O zaman, neden şimdi başlamıyorsunuz?
Neden bu kültürleri kendi içinizde
yaşatmaya başlamıyorsunuz?
Başlamalısınız da.
Beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)